toby is terrible andrew has been so
fantastic in my eyes it was it was
difficult to me to find a new spin on
the character but the main difference is
obviously that I'm much younger than
those guys so we can bring him back to
back to high school and one of the
loveliest things about my part in this
film is that you get to see how a normal
kid would react around the Avengers and
because that's what Peter is he's just a
like a regular kid from Queens who has
been thrown into this mad world so well
it was a funny scene that was the first
scene was shot on set and I reacted
exactly how I reacted when I met Robert
for the first time I was sort of silent
didn't really know what to say was a
very nervous but the way Robert played
it was so sort of warm and so sort of
engaging that I felt comfortable
immediately and he's exactly the same as
that in person
it was definitely overwhelming but there
went when like when you meet these
people you soon realize that they are
just normal people living a crazy
lifestyle and and it was lovely to get
to know them and and to work with them
and to learn from them really so so I'm
very privileged it's definitely a lot of
fun I've been sort of I was in LA for a
bit and I'm here but it's been amazing
fun getting to know these guys and
working with them and and I look forward
to to many more movies in the future I
think trying the suit on for the first
time I mean that for me has been a dream
since I was a kid
this has been amazing
you